I remember in Cujo do you remember that
I just saw it and I didn't know I was
how much did you hate being in that car
if I never see another Pinto again in my
life it will be too soon how how many
days do you think you filmed oh we were
we were in the pinto half of half of the
shooting yeah once you hit the halfway
point the rest of it in the pinto a lot
of people think you know we were dying
at the heat we were actually really
really cold because it was in Northern
California in November and December they
used a mechanical dog they used a bunch
yeah okay there were 13 dogs that played
Cujo all trained to go after toys Saint
Bernards because you could you can't
overwork a dog you can overwork an actor
and then they treated me for exhaustion
for three weeks after that film